so I filed a foia I filed a foia request
to the CIA seeking out all of the
research and communication they did to
structure that tweet as silly as that
sounds the government agencies they get
in a lot of trouble when they post
things out to the general public and
it's wrong wait hold on sorry you filed
a foia for what precisely why did they
make the Tweet or what was the right so
so as the CIA they don't just Tweet
stuff out there's an approval process uh
there are people that need to be
involved fact checking what image is the
CIA going to have by it this particular
tweet so on and so forth sounds
excruciating just a tweet it it is look
it is but what's great about it is the
paper trail
and for people like me that I dig that
and so that's what I did I went after
that paper trail this sounds like a joke
question is there a paper trail for also
what do they hearts and retweets like do
they have to have a reason for
bookmarking for hearting for
well since bookmarking I don't think is
public I don't think that that would be
a protocol liking I would imagine there
wouldn't be a paper trail but more so a
man a social media manual
and I and I've gone uh so protocol
manuals on who has who manages the
social media account so yeah I'm sure
there's rules and procedures for a like
or a share I'm guessing there probably
would be for a share but but the likes
probably not but I'm sure there's
procedures for it okay going back to
your foyer request yeah uh no problem so
so I filed the request for all the
emails all the research you know what
did you guys base this on other than the
document they posted but like who did
this right well the the names were
redacted that's a standard and and and
pretty common uh but essentially the
email exchange was this uh again the
names were redacted so I can't name them
but the one person goes to likely a
supervisor or boss and says hey what
about this because it was World UFO day
around that time so they were trying to
like latch on to World UFO day uh and
put out the Tweet you know in the email
print printed it out the supervisor
essentially said Yep looks good and that
was it now some might think well okay
well that's standard it's just a tweet
well that's generally not how it works
that there are drafts and like they
really kind of get get into this
especially if you're making the claim
that you're taking credit for UFOs from
the 1950s but that was it that was the
basis and the extent of the conversation
and I got those emails uh out and and
that was it
um but why I bring it up is it's
laughable
uh because it that's essentially how
much research they do on UFO related
statements Roswell is another prime
example you know they change their I
don't know what to think about Roswell
I'm not here to argue that it was a
flying saucer or alien craft that
crashed but what I do find funny is the
fact that they needed to change their
story four times over the course of
decades and what I did was I dissected
the fourth one
and even that doesn't line up they were
trying to blame the the alien bodies I
use quotes because I don't know uh but
that the stories related to alien bodies
there's quite a few people that have
that were first-hand information uh
sources that have passed away but but
their stories live on and then others
second hand but there were quite a few
stories they tried to blame that on Air
Force Crash Test Dummies the problem was
that Roswell happened five years before
Crash Test Dummies were even invented so
they're trying to attribute things that
didn't even exist at the time to
something that happened in 1947. they
also said that multiple Air Force
crashes where a few Air Force pilots
were either injured or killed there were
multiple crashes uh those happened both
9 and 12 years after Roswell
so how did how is that connected right
uh but that's what the Air Force says
and again anybody can fact check that so
why is it that every time they speak to
UFO related
cases or questions
they can't they can't get it right they
just can't and when you're talking about
the majority of identifiable objects
which is what they want us to believe
present day why is that you would think
that it would be easier through foia to
get the material it's not you would
think that the information would match
up it doesn't you would think that you
would have somewhat black and white
answers
you don't and I say somewhat because
look the reality is like we talked
earlier drones balloons spy technology
and classified platforms are part of
this conversation whether we like to
believe it or not it just is that's the
reality so you're encroaching
unclassified material so you're
obviously going to find denials and
you're going to find roadblocks that's
expected I get that I navigate those
Bombs all the time on all sorts of
topics but not like this and that's
what's kept me interested for 26 plus
years because they can't get it right
and that's what I can't explain I I
don't know I can't prove it's aliens to
you but I can't prove that you can rule
it out either you know based on the
information at hand if they released
everything we can then have a different
discussion but the reality is is that
they're holding on to so much and in
some cases the most valuable data that
visual stuff a hundred percent of it or
near 100 percent that makes it
impossible to rule anything out or
believe anything and and that's what I
think we need to really tackle is why is
that secrecy there in the first place
because their explanation does not make
sense
does your frustration ever turn to
bitterness
you know bitterness is a good word for
it I get angry you know you can't help
but not when you uh my record for
waiting alone let's not even talk about
the foia games waiting is 14 and a half
years imagine waiting for a request to
be processed for 14 and a half years it
wasn't even a UFO related request the
result wasn't even interesting but it
was 14 and a half years that's that's
incredibly frustrating uh the games that
are played uh connecting it to the UAP
topic one specific one is one that has
frustrated me to no end I've been
fighting it now for two years the U.S
Navy when it comes to UAP related
requests will randomly close the request
and say that they will add responsive
material to their online what they call
reading room
excuse me but they they closed the
request so there's no way to track it
and you don't get updates you just have
to like sit on the page and refresh it
and I recently found cases that were
closed over a year ago UFO related that
had never been added to the reading room
at all so I've been fighting it but
these types of games make it so
incredibly hard for researchers and for
for people like me foia requesters to
make sense of all of it and when they
play those games uh yeah you can't help
but be bitter but there are those that
really do want to help honestly there
are some great foia officers through
some of the agencies there are some that
are awful and they're they're just not
into their job at all there are others
that are there to help and if they don't
know they're open to listen to you in
some cases I've helped foia officers on
sometimes where to look for stuff uh and
I laugh about it but just because I've
been doing it for so long and sometimes
this is just their assignment especially
with um you know different military
facilities and stuff like that sometimes
they're just there for six months and
they get assigned and you know they got
to learn on the job and so on so you
have a wide spectrum of people to deal
with and and it does get frustrating you
become bitter but at the end of the day
I try not to I try and swallow all of
that because the only result is to give
up for me you know and and I'm not gonna
I don't want to so I just have to
swallow all that sometimes it'll come
out my frustration comes out in a a
letter and usually when it does it's
it's well deserved but you just can't
give up I mean that's what they want you
to do and if you stick to your guns you
could be doing it for years or like me
more than 26 for them they're likely not
going to be in that foia office so they
may upset you but they're likely not
going to be there indefinitely so
they'll they'll move on to a different
office or whatever and then you can
either try again or hopefully your
frustration will subside but yeah it
gets challenging I ain't gonna lie it it
gets pretty rough sometimes
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy